The 19th century had a name for it, Bibliomania, that feverish urge to collect books you'd never
open, not for knowledge, not for understanding, but for the sheer weight of possibility.
These were not readers, they were curators of a different kind of devotion, the architecture
of what might have been. And then there was Tuundoku, the Japanese art of letting books
pile up like unpaid debts, each spine a silent accusation against the life you're actually
living. The library becomes a psychological anchor, every unread volume a Zygarnik loop
you've willingly installed in your refuge. You don't just avoid the work you perform, the
avoidance. The books sit there, judging you in their leather-bound silence. Now, consider
the burden of the unopened page. You buy advanced macroeconomics, not because you'll master
it, but because the act of purchase makes you feel like the kind of person who could. The
book is a participation trophy for the intellectual life you've only ever imagined. Behavioral
economists call it the sunk cost fallacy. But in the library, it's worse. It's the sunk
cost of identity. You've already spent the money. You've already claimed the shelf space.
The only thing left is to pretend you're the kind of person who reads. And so the instructions
for intellectual overload begin. First, subscribe to every book review newsletter in existence.
When a title is labeled essential, groundbreaking, or dense, buy it immediately. Don't read the first
page. Just place it at the bottom of a new stack. The recommendation trap is simple. The more you own,
the more you can pretend you're keeping up. Then, use those unread books as a backdrop for your video
calls. Let your colleagues see the aesthetic of your sophistication. The towering spines. The
carefully arranged chaos. Your social identity is built on avoidance coping. And what better proof
of your intellectual rigor than a shelf full of books you'll never touch? Next, convince yourself
these are for reference. Of course you'll need them someday. The visual static of the unread becomes part
of your digital wasteland. A quiet hum of potential that never quite materializes. And finally, prioritize
the books that are good for you. The ones that will make you feel guilty for not reading them. Your leisure time
becomes a masterclass in dead hours, spent staring at a spine instead of actually engaging with a single idea. The
result? You become a shawler of the stack. A fortress of unfulfilled potential. The most well-read person in the room
without ever having to read a word. A monument to the life you never started. And then there's the nightstand
pile. Three dense philosophical texts placed just within reach as you drift off to sleep. The last
thing you see before darkness is a reminder of your own intellectualization of avoidance. A book you
haven't read is a friend you haven't betrayed after all. Keep your friends close. Keep your unread books
closer. Because in the end, the library isn't about knowledge. It's about the performance of it.
And the performance is always better than the reality.